les blocages des raffineries met les
stations-service au régime sec
conséquence les professionnels ont du
mal à s'approvisionner risque la panne
sèche
chez les 700 taxis des civils on est
obligé de s'adapter amis réservoir on
obligé de faire comme tous les gens
particulier dalle est resté une demi
heure car vu dans le salon services or
qu'on aurait assez pour le lendemain
mais à prévisions on vous appelle
maintenant je suis désolé je suis bloqué
arrestation jallet pour une demi heure
donc c'est vrai si l'économie est
impacté mais à tous niveaux
de son côté la fédération française du
bâtiment tire la sonnette d'alarmé
espère un dénouement rapide dans les
yvelines la société blanchard s
installer la celle saint cloud et qui
emploie 12 salariés a déjà annulé des
rendez vous professionnels pour cette
fin de semaine et craint de perdre de
l'argent au risque d'être de se
retrouver à sec de carburant situation
qui n'est pas ado dit parce que ça
entraîne la capacité de nos salariés à
se déplacer sur les chantiers
ça veut dire ne pas remplir les missions
pour lesquelles nos clients nous ont
confié des commandes donc ce sont des
chantiers qui prennent du retard
ce sont des engagements qu'on pourra pas
tenir
ça veut dire aussi une incidence
financière derrière tout ça kiné qui
peut être très très conséquente dans les
pôles médicaux les ambulances des 15
hôpitaux et cliniques yves binois
continue de rouler sans encombre cette
semaine en cas de pénurie constatée par
la préfecture les centres de santé
seront classés comme prioritaires